the five fingers of evolution a thorough
understanding of biology requires a
thorough understanding of the process of
evolution most people are familiar with
the process of natural selection however
this is just one of five processes that
can result in evolution before we
discuss all five of these processes we
should define evolution evolution is
simply change in the gene pool over time
but what is a gene pool and for that
matter what is a gene before spending
any more time on genetics let us begin
with a story imagine that a boat
capsizes and ten survivors swim to shore
on a deserted island
they are never rescued and they form a
new population that exists for thousands
of years
strangely enough five of the survivors
have red hair red hair is created when a
person inherits two copies of the red
gene from their parents if you only have
one copy of the gene you won't have red
hair to make this easier we will assume
that the five non red heads are not
carriers of the gene the initial
frequency of the red hair gene is
therefore 50% or 10 of 20 total genes
these genes are the gene pool the 20
different genes are like cards and a
deck that keep getting reshuffled with
each new generation sex is simply a
reshuffling of the genetic deck
the cards are reshuffled and passed to
the next generation the deck remains the
same 50 percent red the genes are
reshuffled and passed to the next
generation the gene pool remains the
same 50 percent red even though the
population may grow in size over time
the frequency should stay at about 50
percent if this frequency ever varies
then evolution has occurred evolution is
simply change in the gene pool over time
think about it in terms of the cards if
the frequency of the cards in the deck
ever changes evolution has occurred
there are five processes that can cause
the frequency to change to remember
these processes we will use the fingers
on your hands starting from the little
finger and moving to the thumb the
little finger should remind you that the
population can shrink
the population shrinks then chance can
take over for example if only four
individuals survived an epidemic then
their genes will represent the new gene
pool the next finger is the ring finger
this finger should remind you of mating
because a ring represents a couple if
individuals choose a mate based on their
appearance or location the frequency may
change if red-headed individuals only
mate with red-headed individuals they
could eventually form a new population
if no one ever mates with red-headed
individuals these genes could decrease
the next finger is the middle finger the
M and the middle finger should remind
you of the M in the word mutation if a
new gene is added through mutation it
can affect the frequency imagine a gene
mutation creates a new color of hair
this would obviously change the
frequency in the gene pool the pointer
finger should remind you of movement if
new individuals flow into an area or
emigrate the frequency will change if
individuals flow out of an area or
emigrate then the frequency will change
in science we refer to this movement as
gene flow all four of the processes
represented by our fingers can cause
evolution small population size
non-random mating mutations and gene
flow however none of them lead to
adaptation natural selection is the only
process that creates organisms better
adapted to their local environment I use
the thumb to remember this process
nature votes thumbs up for adaptations
that will do well in their environment
and thumbs down adaptations that will do
poorly the genes for individuals that
are not adapted for their environment
will gradually be replaced by those that
are better adapted red hair is an
example of one of these adaptations red
hair is an advantage in the northern
climates because the fair-skinned
allowed ancestors to absorb more light
and synthesize more vitamin D thumbs up
however this was a disadvantage in the
more southern climates where increased
UV radiation led to cancer and decreased
fertility thumbs down even the thumb
itself is an adaptation form through the
process of natural selection the
evolution that we have described is
referred to as micro evolution because
it refers to a
all change however this form of
evolution may eventually lead to macro
evolution or speciation every organism
on the planet shares ancestry with a
single common ancestor all living
organisms on the planet are connected
back in time through the process of
evolution take a look at your own hand
it's an engineering masterpiece that was
created by the five processes I just
described over millions and millions of
years can you recall the five main
causes of evolution from memory if you
can't hit rewind and watch that part
again but if you can give yourself or
your neighbor a big five fingered
high-five